tic TOCs Bryce Hall and Jayden hustler
were arrested on Monday in Lee County
Texas while on a Memorial Day weekend
road trip Bryce was arrested and booked
for possession of marijuana he was
released on a $5,000 cash bond
Jaden was booked for possession of a
controlled substance and possession of
marijuana he was released on an eleven
thousand five hundred dollar cash bond
Bryce and Jaden are housemates and
members of tick tops sway house 20
year-old Bryce has 7 million followers
on the platform gone while 19 year-old
Jaden has 6 billion and Counting it goes
like this the fourth the fifth the minor
fall the major road trip when the
arrests went down Bryce even shared some
videos - tik-tok along the way earlier
this month Bryce announced their road
trip plans asking fans for destinations
suggestions writing the sway boys might
do a whole road trip all the way across
the country in the next few days where
should we stop when a fan questioned -
their getaway plans telling them to stay
home during the current pandemic Bryce
replied most states lifted quarantine
the boys are driving across country
staying out of contact from everyone
it's not that deep
[Music]